well first things first candy let's
start with uh why you were trending on
twitter
this reunion look um explain the look to
me i know you're channeling the mistress
people felt a certain kind of way about
it
okay first of all i'm gonna say this i
did not like that picture
that bravo put out at first that picture
was
horrible okay i hope you do not post
that one
but i had to put up the little video on
my page because
if they didn't give the little the
justice that it needed honey you know
what i'm saying
the theme of this reunion is
this they said was 50 shades of gray
burlesque dungeon that's what we were
told
now i brought the theme
that's what i did now the other girls
they look beautiful
but they just wore beautiful gowns i
brought the beam
so that's all i got to say about that
come on people
stop acting like you don't get it you
should be trending on twitter for the
little
meme that's going around now of she
understood the assignment
[Laughter]
exactly well other than uh people
interpreting the
dress code a little differently how did
reunion go
maybe one word to describe this reunion
i mean what other word to say other than
drama
drama that's the only word i can use to
say
for this group of girls period who had
it the worst
oh my goodness you know okay so
obviously there was going to be a lot to
say between canyon
portia and of course drew but i felt
like
latoya came out on fire
she just got so angry okay did anyone
come out on top from reunion
i wouldn't say anybody had a clear
on top i don't know is there any
resolution
on the did porsha hook up with bolo or
not
front a resolution i don't know about a
resolution
um i would say you have to just watch
why do you think kenya is unwilling to
let this thing go i mean she's given
multiple reasons
i'm talking about it because we're
talking
for me i don't want anybody to be
crucified for
you know living their best life you know
i just was like hoping that she would
let it go
but on the other side of that coin when
i listened to the viewers and how much
they had
spun talking about it i was like okay
well if she didn't talk about it
they wouldn't have been able to talk
about this they wouldn't have had
anything to
watch and i think i heard multiple
women's voices what do you think her
endgame is though is it to get to the
truth
or is it to just shame porsha is it both
somewhere in between
probably somewhere in between it's a
complicated thing because i
on one hand i understand keeping things
private like if it happens in the
bedroom nobody has to
know about it if you don't want them to
but on the flip side
there's it was part of a filmed event
and there's something to be said about
it could be empowering to be like yeah i
did and so what
exactly i mean at the end of the day you
know regardless of whatever
you know portia is a single single woman
so regardless if she did or she didn't
she doesn't have to say anything because
it's her choice if she wants to talk
about her own personal business
and so that was the only thing that i
was you know thinking like you know
she doesn't really have to give anybody
an answer really you know
so you know you guys can try to hold her
to the fire if he wants to but at the
end of the day
she doesn't really have to answer
anybody right
did you hear from her after that scene
between you
and marlo do you feel bush is a liar
oh gosh well put it this way in in our
past history
and dealing with each other yes i've
seen her tell us before
oh no um actually i didn't she didn't
say anything
i did not i did not hear anything from
her about that
what did she say though like portia and
i have definitely had a
roller coaster relationship i mean we
are in a better place now but i mean
it's not like you can't really say
anything to me
because of our history we've definitely
had our moment
well everyone got a kick out of uh at
the big frida dinner
i should have knocked on your door
she was into it you gave her this look
like you should have
cause i'm the phone no just kidding
i wanted to help lighten up the mood
i just felt like it was just way too
intense let's
try to have fun laugh you know
this is too much to do it right here not
do that so
i was definitely trying to help lighten
up the mood
i think as much fun as the viewers have
had
investigating the the bolo situation
there does
seem to be some fatigue of okay how many
more seasons can we watch
kenya and porsha go at it how many more
times can these two be at odds
what do you think the solve is there can
they move forward from this does one of
them need to separate themselves from
the group
where do we go from here actually i
don't know
i hate that they have gotten back on the
wrong foot
but i personally have seen
crazier situations you know
subside and get back you know to a
better place
so i wouldn't say that they couldn't
you know ever fixed it it could be fixed
you know if
kenya and marlowe can fix it kenyan
porsche can fix it i
i definitely feel like we would like to
see them
say okay let's bury the hatchet
there's a lot of chatter about maybe
it's time for a little
cast refresh switch this group up a
little bit what would you like to see
the way i look at it is we just shook
things up
and i feel like people were just
starting to get to know
some of the new people um
in this past season so if anything
i feel like we only had five housewives
this past year i feel like if anything
add somebody you know i don't feel like
we need to
switch it up again because we just
switched it up we just
added new people and i feel like there's
more to get to know
about the new people and i feel like
we could possibly add one more just
just to have a bigger group right when i
saw that i was like this is okay
we're in for a covered season we're in
for a smaller season
you guys delivered you still delivered
iconic moments
the entire charleston trip will go down
in housewives history i've never been in
a sex swing before
have you thought about launching another
business where you curate bachelorette
parties for people
yes well i'm actually i'm about to put
together
a virtual party for everybody to join me
for a little dungeon party like within
the next
few weeks will bolo be there
yes have you spoken to bolo about the
whole ordeal and
does he have any feelings about becoming
a major plot point
we do speak about it not i don't we
don't go too far into detail i don't
ask him any of his personal business
about you know what he did or did not do
or
anything like that but um i think at
first he was a little nervous
about what this could mean for his life
and he was a little afraid to be honest
about
you know how it affect him he has his
own personal relationship
he has a family you know and so um to be
put on this platform could be a little
scary you know
but i just told him you know just keep
your head up
you know you have so much more to offer
the world and just you know just
accept that people are excited to know
more about you just look at it that way
that is i mean i think people would have
been excited
scandal or not after seeing him in that
chanel suit and all he had to offer
candy hey just look at the bright side
well he
he's been on well when i took the
dungeon on tour
everybody goes crazy when he hits the
stage
let me just say that okay crazy
does not surprise me at all they love it
i can tell you that um have you spoken
to
tanya since she opted to step
back from the group after that trip and
the conversations around it
no we haven't had an actual conversation
are you surprised that she checked out
after that
not really i think it was a lot for her
you know
um overall we have to remember that
people have
lives outside of the show and you know
the thing that
if nothing else that you know about team
the thing that's most important for her
is her relationship with paul and
anything that's going to jeopardize that
she doesn't want any part of it
i mean she was doing well for herself
before she came on the show
so it's not like her life depended on
real housewives of atlanta right
we have only a handful of episodes left
before
these reunion episodes start it seems
like the drew latoya saga
takes another turn what can you tell me
about the preying on prophets
drama you're playing with the church
you're playing with the prophets
you're preying on prophets and you got
that delilah spirit you've been out
i still don't understand that whole
situation i felt like
drew got a little too invested in that
in my opinion
i mean okay i get it you know she
she felt like she kept calling latoya a
delilah
i was like what you know
and it just you know it just gets weird
to me
you know when somebody starts being real
judgy about another person and started
using religion to
um shun someone and
it's just like okay this is too much you
know what i mean and so for me
it was going in a place that i felt like
it shouldn't you know i got that
they didn't get along but that whole
telling her she was praying on your
profit situation was too much it was
like he's a grown man he's single
like he makes his own decision like like
you cannot blame
latoya for anything that that man
decides to do like stop it
well i am excited to see what plays out
in these last couple episodes is there
anything you're super excited for the
viewers to see
hmm yeah blaze
you know um no i was super excited to
see you know
my restaurant blaze actually open and
the girls come through
um on the show because it's like to know
that
before they announced the pandemic is
when we had signed our new leaves for
our restaurants to be able to still pull
through and still make things happen
you know we were very um happy that it
still came together and everybody's
fine and everything is good so i was
happy about that
i'm ready for the cameras to go up on
that olg
show that may or may not be happening
candy
we're supposed to be coming back
together very soon
you also have envy coming out on
lifetime
why do people need to tune in to envy
well envy this show is
super good i'm super excited to be a
part of a lifetime movie growing up i
always watch lifetime movies you know
how you just sit there all day
well this is definitely one that's going
to make you want to be glued to the tv
did i tell you i have a stunt double in
this movie
i never had to use a stomp double before
but this one
i was sitting there when it happened i
was like oh oh
glad i had a stunt dog you know what i
just thought about it
sometimes i feel like i need a stunt
double on um rhoa
[Laughter]
no but seriously um it gives you a
little bit of everything it um
this movie it it's it's it's it's one of
those things where
it's enough drama enough uh
enough heart it makes you feel feel
something for
the characters where you feel sorry for
but then at the same time you like you
don't like her
same like like rhoa like housewives
and then at the end you know you want to
say a little prayer for it and you want
them all to come back together and
show a little love to bring them all
back together at the end you know it's
all the
all the great ingredients to make a
great movie
[Music]
you